على مدى عقود تبحث مراكز استطلاعات الراي
في توجهات الاتراك ساعيا لرسم المشهد
الانتخابي ينطلق الباحثون بين الناس
لقراءه افكارهم وبناء صوره تقريبيه للفائز
تصيب هذه الاستطلاعات وتخطئ لكنها تبقى
محكومه بعده عوامل اهمها المنهج العلمي
المتبع في الاستطلاع وتصميم العينه
المستطلعه بالاضافه الى توجه اصحاب هذه
المراكز والباحثين فيها فقد يسعى مركز
لترجيح كفه مرشح على الاخر سعيا للتاثير
الفعلي في النتائج النهائيه لكننا اليوم
نعيش عصر الذكاء الاصطناعي فهل ثمه فروق
بينما يقراه الباحثون في الميدان
والباحثون وراء الشاشات دعونا نقارن
سناخذ احدث استطلاعا للراي اجراه مركز
كوندا ابرز مركز تركي ومعه بحث عبر الذكاء
الاصطناعي اجراه فريق الجزيره تحديدا من
خلال نسخه الخاصه المحدثه من برنامج شات
يستند استطلاع الراي الميداني الى مقابله
اكثر من 3600 شخص في منازلهم في 34 مقاطعه
تركيه يستند الذكاء الاصطناعي الى نتائج
من الجوله الاولى ونماذج التصويت
التاريخيه والتاييدات الاخيره بعد الجوله
الاولى وفق البحث الميداني يقول استطلاع
الراي ان الرئيس اردوغان سيحصل على
52.7 اعشار في المئه مقابل 47 وثلاثه عشر
في المئه لكمال كالجدار اوغل يذهب الذكاء
الاصطناعي للاستناد بشكل كبير على ما
وصفناه بالتاييدات الاخيره التركيز بطبيعه
الحال هنا على اصوات المرشح الخاسر سنان
اوغان حصل اوغان على
خمسه.7 في المئه وبعدها اعلنت تاييده
للرئيس اردوغان يستند الذكاء الاصطناعي
الى فرضيه انخفاض الاقبال على التصويت في
الجوله الثانيه وما حساب الممتنعين عن
التصويت واعدادهم وتوقع توجهاتهم يقول
الذكاء الاصطناعي ان اردوغان سيحصل على
53.68% مقابل
46.32% لكم
اما بالنسبه للتغيرات المتوقعه فتقول
مراكز استطلاع الراي ما راى الناخبين
ستتغير وفق تاثير الاحداث التي ستجري في
اسبوع الانتخابات والتحولات في التحالفات
بعد الجوله الاولى ومعدل المشاركه في
الجوله الثانيه بالنسبه للذكاء الاصطناعي
يقول ان اراء الناخبين ستتغير وفق
ديناميكيات الحمله الانتخابيه للمرشحين
والاخبار بالاضافه الى التغييرات في
المشاعر العامه بين استطلاع ات الراي
وذكاء الاصطناعي ستبقى كل هذه التفاصيل
مرهونه فقط بما سيقوله الاتراك داخل
صناديق الاقتراع